most of the things that I guess other
people might see is failure I don't say
it's failure what's a failure I really
didn't do well like I choked on the hair
while I was talking and I guess a lot of
the things that most people would see is
failure I don't see as failure I don't
even see this feedback it just was and
now we're moving on I Don't Look
Backwards right it's like okay whatever
that's done cool let's go forward oh you
have feedback for me cool I filmed
without the microphone was out of
failure I see it as a win I don't think
I take big enough risks to ever have a
real failure like if I mortgaged my
house to make this day like insane and
Danny says Hey to make this thing fly we
need Val kilm or riding on an elephant
like crashing through the front door and
then that had to work or I lost my house
that's a failure to me so everything
else is all manageable I think it's a
strength and a weakness it limits how
much upside I have but this also means a
zero downside
so as somebody who has done how many
videos have you done on YouTube Jesus
I have no idea eight thousand three more
three point one thousand on your main
Channel there's more that's that's like
public but there's more there's like
there's a lot that are that are being
re-uploaded uh no it's like I would say
15 000. okay so that's huge that's many
many opportunities to make mistakes yeah
I was somebody who thought were 1100
episodes into a podcast it's gonna be
fine we're never gonna make any more
mistakes I've made more mistakes in the
last year than I have my prior lives
what was your relationship with failure
like at the beginning when you were
again in a suit not a tuxedo talking
about Walt Disney versus today are you
the default like Alan failure is
necessary or were you it's part of the
course it doesn't affect me I will go
get better or did you go lick your
wounds what was your process like I
think
that I honestly play too small to fail I
think it's I think it's part mindset in
part like most of the things that I
guess other people might see is failure
I don't see his failure what's a failure
if you didn't do well like I choked on a
hair while I was talking I don't know
like what's what's failure
and I guess a lot of the things that
most people would see is failure I don't
see as failure I don't even see this
feedback I don't know it's just it just
was and now we're moving on I Don't Look
Backwards right it's like okay whatever
that's done cool let's go forward oh you
have feedback for me cool suggestion I
filmed without the microphone was that a
failure I see it as a win right so I
don't really
how did you get there how did you get to
the point where nothing is a failure
well again I I couched it in I don't
think I take big enough risks to ever
have a real failure right like if uh I
mortgaged my house to make this day like
insane right and you know Danny says Hey
to make this thing fly we need Val
Kilmer riding an elephant like crashing
through the front door I don't know
where it's coming from
that would go viral and like and that's
that and then that had to work or I lost
my house right that's a failure to me
right like if it doesn't work I'm like
really on the line to make this thing
happen
I don't know why Val Kilmer came up but
so I don't really ever put myself in
that and maybe that's to my detriment
like to to Walt Disney I've like putting
everything on the line twice to build
this company I've never been in that
situation where it takes such a big risk
so everything else is all manageable you
know I don't see it I think it's a
strength and a weakness it limits how
much upside I have but this it also
means a zero downside so I don't know
like if if none of this gets recorded
and Danny really screwed up okay is that
a failure maybe but I'm not even
remember it's like okay Danny next time
like press record and then we'll have do
you think that affects your ability to
connect and or help other people because
they're so focused on what you're not
sometimes there are some things that are
easy to connect with me on so if I'm
talking about being introvert and being
shy and hating my first videos and being
super uncomfortable on stage and being
nervous before I go off and do anything
um
over judging and over analyzing and I
haven't believed and like all that's how
people can really connect to that's
super easy so that's where I'll lean in
on for the most part uh stuff like that
is harder stuff like
continue my tour with a broken neck is
harder stuff like damned Doritos and
having the bag just because I'm stronger
than Doritos like it's what they don't
they don't get that right Achievers
might right that's like Navy SEAL stuff
uh but it's not what I lead with like
people always ask me like can you have a
healthy sponsor like why is Dorito
sponsoring you like you know you're
supposed you're on you're on a
trampoline desk and jumping and you and
why not get a healthier spot like
Doritos has a sponsor my videos guys if
you knew why I had this bag in three
years behind me like Doritos would never
respond to me damn the Doritos so I have
a bunch of weird things like that that
um
people would not connect with me on most
people but Achievers would the Navy
Seals would uh so I just have to it's
like who's your audience who you talking
to
right so if I'm talking to you guys it's
going to be a different story if I'm
talking to somebody off the street who's
like struggling to
take the first step have you always been
an achiever have you have you when did
you when in hindsight were you always an
achiever
uh I think I was a selective achiever I
honestly think I still am a selective
achiever you know like there's some
things that if I don't if I don't want
to do it forget it
you know like I could be the best
student or the worst can you give us an
example uh if I am bored
I am the worst student
like Nina can attest we if I'm learning
something I'm really into it it's like
focused like shut up don't talk like I
want to learn this thing because this
person is dropping knowledge and like
I'm trying to get this thing and I don't
want to be distracted or anything where
there are some dance classes we've been
to where uh like the teacher I got it
and then they're like reviewing and
teaching the same thing okay this is boy
so I'm just gonna do my own thing
and like I start to zone out and and not
pay attention to the teacher at all
anymore so if I think earlier in life I
didn't necessarily know the difference
or the distinction between the two where
I felt like I was an achiever I was not
because I wasn't doing well in school
like no I wasn't failing I was getting
like B's and c's for most of my school
until my last year
and uh so I would I wouldn't necessarily
identify as an achiever but I was
achieving in other things
and I think a lot of most people are
selective Achievers I think most people
you could be an achiever you're just
doing the wrong stuff things that don't
inspire you things that don't you don't
feel connected to when did you start
identifying as an achiever because I
think when people don't identify as an
achiever maybe their relationship with
failure doesn't improve because if you
are an achiever you're going to have to
redefine what failure means to you
anyway because the only way to improve
is to fail forward I think once I
started getting results like I don't
think it was one moment again where like
oh I'm achiever now oh light bulb it was
more like oh this thing that I'm doing
is actually working like this thing that
I care about I mean there's that moment
for you where it's like holy crap this
is actually working like that momentum
moment of
I mean probably the first time was when
I was five years old and I sold the
painting to my next-door neighbor for 10
cents
you know like I convinced my
three-year-old little sister to like
draw a whole bunch of things and then we
went to her around the neighborhood and
like sold it and for five or ten cents
our next neighbor paid us for the guys
like yeah
let's go
got 10 cents but
uh
and then in garage sales like I used to
collect baseball cards and in 92-93 the
Blue Jays in Toronto won the World
Series and it was also like the height
of of uh trading cards baseball cards
like that was the peak era so combine
that plus like Toronto win the World
Series back to back it's like baseball
insane in the city and I would uh I
would buy and sell baseball cards you
were like 12 around that time 12 and 13.
and my parents would take me every
weekend to this um place a couple hours
away that they sold like people would
come and buy and sell cards and I would
I would negotiate with 40 year olds that
felt like ancient like I'm 42 now but
like when I'm 13 these guys feel like
they're ancient like their life is over
40 Jesus
and and uh
I would negotiate over a dollar you know
and our dollars are coins right we have
loonies and I remember a guy saying well
I'll give you a dollar but it's got gum
on it it's like okay I'll take the gum
off like it's a dollar let's go like I
just rip this guy off let's go we're
crushing it
uh so like in those little moments where
like I feel like as a 12 year old I
outnegotiated a 40 year old I'm sure
he's like okay whatever stupid kid I
didn't want that thing with the gum on
it anyway and little moments like we had
a uh my grandparents had a garage sale
and
I said hey can I come and sell my
baseball cards at the garage sale and I
ended up selling more dollars of cards
and they sold of all of their
furniture and TVs and like whatever else
they were selling it's like I got
something here like I'm pretty Kick-Ass
and 12 or 13.
um but those are moments I didn't
necessarily then say like oh I'm an
achiever and I'm going to be an
entrepreneur because it was weird nobody
entrepreneur wasn't a thing there was
nobody to look up to
like there was no path that I could see
and I wasn't Visionary enough to say I'm
going to launch this company
so it was like these little pockets or
these moments that I could think about
but uh uh I guess in those moments I
identified as an achiever I felt really
good but I wouldn't necessarily say like
I am in a cheaper like every day when
did you first read that book which
was because that's
probably the first time you
put way bigger than I'm doing it
that book was
when I was how old was I in that book I
think I'd already sold my company so
it's even I had to dance up before
that book uh
uh the first book I read was either I
think the first book I read was um
Donald Trump's book
um what's his book
think big and kick something like that
no no no no like his first one his old
school he wrote in the 80s
um we were driving to New York I didn't
know anything about New York and
the only books I had read up to that
point were Michael Crichton
Michael Crichton wrote like Jurassic
Park and Congo and like he was the only
person I could read I hated reading it
was not fun for me but for whatever
reason give me Michael Crichton book and
like in three days the whole book would
be done I just like I would stay up all
night and just read Michael Christ for
whatever reason I don't know why
but we're going to New York for the
first time we're driving through and I
think that's my parent I don't know how
old I was eight or nine or ten or
something and uh
Donald Trump was like the King of New
York for entrepreneurs way before
President and all the controversy and
all that stuff
um and his first book I forget what it
was called but in that there was we had
a line like I always like thinking big
if you're going to be thinking at all
you might as well be thinking big
like huh that's interesting you know and
so like that started me down the path of
oh there are other books to read besides
Michael Crichton fiction and maybe I can
learn from somebody who's like done
business stuff because I like business
stuff and uh
but that was only one book right and
then it might have been a year before I
read like a Tony Robbins book or
something else right it was like this
little tiny hit but it didn't turn into
a habit until you know much later right
it's like when somebody goes to the gym
for the first time do they go to the gym
and then all of a sudden they're
committed every day and they're at the
gym it's probably they go to the gym to
try something like okay well that was
cool and then like maybe three months
later they go back or a year later they
go back it's like what was the thing
that actually made the difference I
don't know what sparked them to go into
the gym the first time just like this we
start and stop at the beginning and then
even my first video we I don't think I
made another video until like three or
four or five months afterwards it wasn't
like I just made a video and then We're
Off to the Races it took a long time
before I made my next video it was just
a test I would say one of the most
painful and again it's not a failure
it's it's a lesson but for us has been
the expectations of others versus the
expectations of ourselves how have the
expectations that you have on other
people changed over the course of the
year I have on other people yeah or
others have on me no I would well you
could you could do both but yeah I'm
thinking like when you because I know in
one of our previous interviews you
talked about how you often believe more
on other people than they believe in
themselves and that can get that can get
dangerous has that shifted has that
changed over the years
depends on the person
um
like I want you guys to make history we
appreciate that
like and that's it
nothing else like falling short doesn't
count
so that's an expectation you can accept
it you cannot but every time I meet you
it's like okay what's the next step to
make history I don't care if you'd say
you don't want it because you need it
I don't know it's like it's the vibe
it's like okay that has to happen that's
right Vibes yeah that's the vibe from
you guys it's like you don't want to
stay small yeah yeah and you want to go
faster so okay so how do we make history
how do you know so say we come to you
and we say Evan we're going to crush it
we're going to change the world
and then you give us advice like hey
your thumbnails kind of suck change them
how do you know whether or not somebody
is actually in it for what they say
they're in it for like what's the line
of demarcation for that I almost always
give people a test
was that a test we got no no you already
passed a test like that was stupid like
you should have done it right like but
but that's good like sometimes listen if
you're if you're training somebody if
you're if you hire a trainer and you
don't show up for the workout like you
hope your trainer calls you out on and
says dude what are you doing right not
for them like you're paying them anyway
but for you you say you want this you
got to go do it
um I'll even apply more pressure on it's
like dude like I spent my time on this I
could have been doing a million other
things and I spend my dinner with you
pull up your laptop and spending like
the whole night looking at your stupid
thumbnails and you don't do the work you
mean I don't even care right it's just
like to add more
more weight to it it's like go do
something man make history but I still
remember it yeah
yeah I'm gonna remember that
he's gonna ask us tomorrow and I know
it's like no we're still talking about
years later I'm not forgetting that yeah
I'll give people a test and then like
for you guys you came you came here
oh yeah like you drove to come here to
do the the interview
right I don't remember how we set it up
it was a it was a super throwaway right
like hey guys I'm gonna be doing this
thing in Toronto you were the only ones
who came from anywhere else like
everybody in that room was from here
Toronto yeah and then you know I'm still
a client
yeah anyways sorry well your client yeah
oh yeah so you like you met him as a
client yeah oh cool it was really cool
yeah so
I said hey I'm doing this event for
torontoerners if you want to do an
episode of the show or I forget what I
wrote um but then you said okay well
yeah we'll be there and you drove up and
you were here and spent the day and cool
um I love those I love those little
tests that starts to speak a lot to who
the per whether it works out or not
whether you ask like dumb ass questions
like it doesn't matter because you'll
get better right
if they're if you're willing to put in
the work you'll get better definitely so
I'll put everybody through little tests
Alex who helps me run this when he when
he uh start he was the worst student and
also the the worst so we go like student
helper assistant instructor right so
then you're teaching uh he got he he had
to do every level twice which we like
never hold students back
but he got held back every semester
because he was so bad at dancing
and then Sharon who's the original owner
of the school took a bet on him to be uh
uh an assistant
and like dude no not Alex like this guy
is so bad and I was his friend you know
it's like you like not Alan dude Allen
is so bad he can't dance and the worst
part with Alex was he wasn't taking
feedback so he was in my I was teaching
level six which was the highest level
class
he was dancing right there as a helper
in the class and thought he knew like
everything and it would come around and
give him feedbacks like don't do like
move your hand up higher you're taking
too big a step and he would never listen
to the feedback maybe it's because I was
his friend he knew me whatever like okay
whatever I don't care don't let the
feedback
but Intel and share like this guy never
takes feedback he's never going to get
better don't make him an instructor
this is a this is a waste of time
and then uh the model is you have a
woman and a guy at the front right so
Sharon was teaching Alex was the
assistant Sharon then hurts her back and
like can't teach like out on the floor
like it's a physical it's not just show
up and do a podcast and talk like I did
with my broken neck like you can't dance
she couldn't move her back so uh I was
to the Evan you have to go teach the
class like the higher level class you
have you have to go teach the class
because I can't teach
and that means Alex is out because you
can't have two guys at the front of a
class you need you need a man and woman
uh
and Alex is not depressed he comes and
picks me up at my house he's driving
over here and he's like I guess you know
I don't you know I don't know how I'm
Gonna Keep learning I guess I'll watch
you from the side because now he's on
now he's on the bench he was in the game
now he's on the bench
and I said okay dude two options one I
could teach the class and I'll and I'll
just help you like I don't Sharon
committed to you so all in honor of her
like I'll continue the training your
problem is you don't listen so whatever
I'll keep going for a semester if you
shape up I'll help you otherwise you're
out but I'm only doing this because
Sharon believes in you and from our
experience like you didn't listen any
feedback so to his credit like you turn
that around because the first test was
crap because he's not listening to
anything right
um like if you didn't go back and do the
thumbnails like I'm not giving you
YouTube advice again like go do
something dude Jesus
uh
so we're in the car driving to CDs here
and I on the car on the way in it's like
say I can either teach the class and
I'll help you at the back afterwards and
you just watch and learn from me and
hopefully we have a chance in a couple
months whatever for you to do something
or you do the class
and I'll coach you from the sidelines
because we both can't be at the front
so you do the class which he was wholly
like unprepared for like he's the
assistant a class might be 60 60 Minutes
long maybe he's teaching like three four
minutes of the class
now he's got to teach the whole class
and run the show and like welcome people
and like do the whole thing he's not
ready for it and he's like 15 minutes
away from having to do it for the whole
night
and he said okay I'll do it like okay
let's go and he did it and he sucked it
wasn't like total suck it wasn't like he
fell on the floor or something right but
it was not it was what you would expect
of somebody who didn't have the
experience coming in and now having to
lead through and he's nervous and he's
like freaking out but whatever he did it
like I don't care how well he did I care
that he did it
he did it it's like okay you know I'm
going to bet on this guy and that
started the turnaround for Alex
uh so everybody I give these little
tests you guys came out and drove from
Boston to come do the thing like okay
that's some hustle I like these guys
right you ask great questions on the
first podcast like I don't remember any
of the podcasts I did on my whole tour I
was just like ate a day for 90 days or
something it was crazy how many podcasts
I was doing like I like these guys
you're the first choice to come here and
dude I'm not saying that because we
turned four of the guys down and you
were actually the first ones
to come and do this so everybody gets
some kind of test right when I first met
Danny he had a uh he posted something on
Instagram
um that I liked and he came and he
filmed so if you come film a day with me
and he filmed the day in the life of and
like filmed a whole bunch of shots which
isn't even like Danny Danny doesn't like
following people around and doing stuff
he likes like these set high production
like which for me is actually awkward I
like moving around and doing stuff he he
cares so much about the visual
that when you're moving and the lighting
is changing and all that stuff it it's
it's it's frustrating but he came when
he did it it's like and I like them it's
like I like this guy
right and then he he uh and he had a
business partner at the time and like
and that ended up didn't work he's like
I like Danny I like Danny we're going
with Danny let's go Danny and and so
like everybody gets a little test
so that relationship with failure
transfers to the way you run businesses
and also transfers to helping other
people with their relationship with
failure because Alex was in over his
head yeah and you were okay with that
and you were willing to fail on his
behalf but fail forward for lack of
better phrasing so that he could get
better and so you apply that to
everybody
how did he feel about his performance
he thought he sucked you know
um right and listen he did but that's
where it's like I don't where is he at
right now he doesn't need to be beaten
up for how crappy it was because it was
pretty bad like it wasn't so bad that
people were going to like leave negative
reviews on Google to say this guy sucks
and everybody in the class knew Sharon
and she had a backache and so like is
that there's the story to know like what
happened so there's a little bit of
understanding as opposed to him just
starting fresh
um
but that's the point where I need to
build them up it's like okay
I had to pick I would pick three things
a night of what feedback to give them
that would be constructive to improve
yeah where I could have said a thousand
things dude like everything was a train
wreck could it like every minute we
could have broken down different pieces
but you picked like the three most
important ones to focus on and then
build him up to say what the what the
like what went well and then go to the
next one there was one moment where I
had to teach in level three
you have to do double turns so you have
to go you have to spin twice on one
count which is it's it's the it's one of
those moves that starts to separate the
beginner from the intermediate level
dancer and Alex's spins weren't great
he's like dude I can't I can't teach I
can't teach a double turn can you go and
teach double turn for me like I'll teach
the class but you teach the double turn
at the front like dude no Fu man I'm not
teaching the double turn you teach
double turn
and so like he's we're having a
conversation right there that at the DJ
room and it's like okay you go do it and
unless you like I will only come in and
if you just like fall on your face and
have like I won't let you fall so hard
that it's like a total disaster but I'm
not coming in to save you on these
little things and it's the same feedback
that I gave Alex just yesterday he is
training instructors and he's such a
perfectionist that he doesn't allow the
instructor to make enough mistakes on
their own and so he's training a girl
she's an assistant she has eight minutes
of a 60-minute class he films the eight
minutes and sends it to me it's like
what do you think about her and and like
how should how should she move and what
she should be doing different and I gave
her a little bit of feedback but the
biggest thing is she's just nervous like
she's saying all the right things but
she's telling your jokes and she's doing
it in your way and she's just nervous
and she'll get it like just encourage
her and let her feel more comfortable
and then I gave him like pages of notes
on what he sucked at in the class right
because as she's teaching he's demoing
the moves as she's taking saying you're
taking too big a step he's taking Giant
Steps he's counting things out with his
hands he's telling people what to do
like let her run the class dude she
makes one little tiny like half a second
I'm not sure what to do and he says it's
like this right in front of the whole
class like you're making her look bad to
the students and to herself let her
figure it out and only save her if it's
a total disaster
by you putting the energy on you in the
class even though it's to serve like in
that class was a better student
experience which is what he's thinking
about
the students will get it more if he's
teaching but then then you never scale
like you need to be a you need to be
wallpaper she's running the whole class
you're this there assistant and you're
saying zero and there's zero energy on
you and let her run the whole thing and
then you pull her aside afterwards and
you say Okay that was really good here's
here are the things to fix on the next
time when did that pivot for you in the
delegation process where you were
comfortable being the wallpaper and and
allowing it to be right away like with
Alex it was from the first session you
were always like that in all your
businesses with with team members was
that always easy for you to just be able
to sit back and take the short-term L
for the long-term win
in terms of scale I don't know when did
that first start happening like I like
co-creation
right it has to ultimately work but I
like co-creation so if I'm filming with
Danny on something it's like okay I I
didn't set this up right like I got
three chairs and then Danny's I didn't
tell them what lights to bring I don't
know about lights like that looks like
we have the sun in the eye look how
giant that thing is it's crazy right
Danny we're co-create I didn't say three
cameras I don't know what microphone
we're using it's like you're co-creating
with the person because I only know so
much and I have my way of doing things
that it may not be exactly now
especially with someone like Danny who's
like an expert at what he does in
filming I know zero like me suggesting
what gear to use is ridiculous right but
even in things that I'm teaching I'm
willing to be surprised so if I have a
way of teaching it I like to see how
somebody else
would teach it even if it's not perfect
because ultimately they have to find
their own path they can't only be a
junior Evan there's only one person in
my company who I need to think exactly
like me and that's Ivan who does all my
uh the key research for the channel
because in like selecting the clips and
the topics it's like it's got to be the
same way that I would look at it right
and so I trained him for a year every
week we met
for a year looking at the clips and
saying here I would cut it here I
wouldn't include that that's not really
believe so that he could think the way
that I think everybody else we've got 42
people on the team or something from
what thumbnails and what pictures and
all of it it's like let's co-create what
do you want to make together JP comes up
with some idea for what to do with the
video cool like let's jive with that he
wants to start like running around and
you know taking some crazy aerial shots
with a cooler like I'm down like and
maybe it sucks and maybe he ends up
breaking his camera and we lose awesome
like next it's an experiment like you
see if it works or not but those are all
mini failures right like what's the
worst case scenario I guess GP loses his
camera but it's not like Val Kilmer on
an elephant
mortgaging my house and we lose the
whole thing right you talked about how
you unpack the experience with Alex when
you're on stage and I know you don't
live in the past but when you're on
stage and you step off stage what are
your thoughts are you grateful you did
it and you say this is where I need to
improve do you say it that really sucked
and I need to get better what's your
problem immediately it's like now the
real work like now the real fun starts I
get off stage and I'm going to spend six
hours in the hallway talking to people
that's my favorite part speaking on
stage does almost nothing for me it's
the it's the it's the setup to the
conversations the hallways what is it
that you're optimizing for most
because it seems like momentum to me
that which is why you're so fluid with
the co-collaboration and all that
whereas other people are optimizing not
to look bad and I think that that's a
really big strength you have and I'm
looking forward to asking you about your
weakness early on too
uh I don't know that I'm only focused on
one thing to optimize for
uh I think it depends on the situation
but when I'm I guess in flow I'm
optimizing to have fun you know or
optimizing for fulfillment
yeah like what am I optimizing for in
this what are we doing here I don't know
it's fun I'm asking questions hopefully
it's good you guys get content we get
content I like it I don't know it might
be it might suck and go nowhere I don't
know who knows like but I'm optimizing
to have fun with you guys and hopefully
make something that's helpful for people
so it's impact right and having fun in
that mix like it was just it was just
let's hang out like no I don't want to
see you guys
right so it's it's both so yeah like
it's got to lead to something right
purposeful that's not you it's anybody
like I don't want to hang out with
anybody I don't I don't like hanging out
it's not fun but if we're making content
and it's going to serve somebody else
like let's go I'm ready I'm down for
that right so the the hallway
conversations are more like I want
people when they come to an event to go
home and do something right like you
came here cool you got motivated
inspired awesome like make a change what
are you gonna do because nothing changes
in your life if you just show up to
event get motivated then go home you
gotta do something so often I've I find
I'm better at giving the specific advice
to people when I'm one-on-one with them
and I feel the energy from them more
than when I'm on a stage and like 5 000
people clapping doesn't mean as much as
like one person in the hallway saying oh
my God that's crazy so that's the most
fun thing for me to do
um I I mean I just spoke uh
at an event it was me and garyvee and
Alex hermosi and Patrick B David and a
bunch of like entrepreneurs in that
world and uh I spoke and then
there was somebody else and then garyvee
was after and he he was the last one I
think of the day and I was in the
hallway like talking to people and then
after all the VIPs or whatever we're
gonna go meet Gary and like do something
photo shoot or whatever and I'm I'm
still talking to the hallway
it's like oh we're gonna go do the thing
with Gary He's like okay but I'm gonna
I'm gonna stay here in the hallway
you're gonna go meet Gary like I've met
Gary Gary doesn't care if I'm there like
it's not like I love Gary he's great
amazing but like he also doesn't care if
I show up or not he's not like pissed
off if I don't show up to his thing I
want to be here helping like these
people because this is this is what I
came for
so that's I whenever I'm going to an
event I try to I try to speak as early
in the schedule as possible
because I want to maximize my time in
the hallway afterwards so hopefully I
see something on stage that leads to a
conversation afterwards when I'm done on
stage I don't even know what I said I
don't watch back my content like
whatever it's like I just want to go and
help people in the hallway and I hope
I'm not the last speaker because I then
people go home and leave and I want to
just help as much as possible how do you
know if you're getting better as a
speaker I don't know that I actually
measure it uh I think breakthrough
moments have been more with me not
memorizing speeches and going off and uh
saying
more what's on my heart and free flow
like the first time I did it was I would
go off and do all these memorized
speeches and and it was fine like slides
the slides would always save me what's
on the slide say what's on the slide
next easy you know and it was still it
still was helpful for people it's I
still want all these speaking Awards and
whatever
um but then I did a keynote in France
and uh I promised myself I don't have
one slide and it terrified me like I was
a closing keynote at this event I forgot
how much it was paid to be there but it
was you know a good amount of money and
I was gonna have one slide the whole
thing for an hour
and I ended up memorizing like word for
word my speech
uh but I did it you know like I
delivered because I had no fallback
option right that's where I guess like a
moment where I could have failed if I
just completely forgot that's a moment
of risk but I ended up crushing it uh
but that gave me permission to play more
and have less I hate slides like I I
will almost never do slides unless it's
absolutely required by the host and even
then I'll still do as little as possible
just to like because they'll get a
better experience when we did our thing
in your world within right it was
Fireside q a yeah it's like I would
rather do a q a
because you know your audience better
than I do you know what they're
struggling with let's solve their
problems instead of me getting up and
pretending like I know and then having
my set presentation for an hour right
I'd much rather do q a most people are
afraid of doing that so you have to have
options but I try to make it as
interactive as possible with with that
would have terrified earlier Evan like I
would have had to known if you guys are
coming here exactly what all your
questions are and then a follow-up
questions and follow-up questions
because I'd be worried about
disappointing you
uh how early on me was that
because it's been a lot not since we've
met you you haven't been concerned about
that from our perspective anyways
I don't know
yeah I remember one moment where there
was a woman who I met at a coffee shop
it was pretty early on and uh
I was afraid of disappointment like this
whole fear of disappointment
uh I was hoping she would I would
secretly help people cancel on me like I
hope they cancel I hope you guys don't
come so I don't have to do this I hope
you cancel out you're sick
kidding everyone thought you were
terrorists whatever cool like you can't
make an awesome great great you're
hanging with Val Kilmer or whatever like
something happened you can't make it
awesome uh mostly because I would be
afraid of disappointing you that I
wouldn't know what uh what the answer I
hope I would bring value I don't want
you to come and like waste your time
especially if you're coming from far you
know you guys got to drive home and I
remember going to this one um this one
woman a coffee shop in Toronto it was
like five minute walk from my place and
we agreed to meet however long ago in
like two hours before I'm hoping she
cancels no email an hour before no email
half an hour before no emails okay sorry
I'm gonna say I'm gonna go because I'm
not gonna not show up
and so my whole morning was not very
productive because I was kept looking at
my email waiting for her to cancel on me
and then I ended up going and it's like
man it was so amazing it's like this is
so great I love what I do I feel amazed
and I help this woman it's pure startup
like an easy easy peasy to help her I
remember getting getting back and um I I
sit in my car and uh I'm about to drive
home and then I fall back like wow like
I feel so great
and I like an hour ago wanted this not
to happen
I need to like fix my relationship to
this thing
this fear of disappointing people and it
still is there uh but I can manage it
better and navigate it better and
there's been a lot of these steps so
like I don't want to know the questions
and people will sometimes submit like
podcast people will submit here are
here's our format here's our questions
here's what we ask every guest like cool
Sandra and my sister
I'm not saying any of this seven I don't
you just want to know just go ask him
but what's off what's off topic
nothing's off topic I mean he'll let you
know if you touch something I don't know
that's like massively off topic
um and it's ended up become a lot more
fun as opposed to me having rehearsed
like it's better for for the show
and it's more fun for me to not have
rehearse prepared everything in advance
but it's been this gradual process of
Letting Go we talked downstairs about
the fact that there's logic and emotion
and I think you're a very logical human
being but we based on what Alex said
there's a lot of the ways that you help
people emotionally that is our next
oh okay you guys want to watch that
video go click it right there we'll see
you there we'll leave